hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer questions from
one of our readers ga goo asking hello
Evan please kindly help me with tips on
rebuilding failing business processes or
strategies to rebuilding a failed
business looking forward to favorable
response Gina so the first thing I look
at is what is the vision of the company
does it have a vision or something that
you can come in with and create a new
vision for the business because it's
gotta be something you can get behind
something really passionate about it
that you notice we're gonna help a lot
of people there's no right or wrong
vision as long as the something that you
feel that you can really get behind and
we're really excited about so that we
want to make sure there is a good
fishing for the business that you can
get behind
number two is look at the staff that's
currently involved with the business
soon there's some kind of team on the
company and see you know do you have the
right two men on board
if you've changed the vision or if
there's a new visual coming in can
everybody get behind it do you have the
right people on the bus with your
company and looking at the skill sets
that they have and seen as a match up of
what you need for the business and
hopefully there's some people there who
can stay on and can help build the
company and take it to that next step
but definitely making sure that your
team is on board and you have the right
people in place and you might have to go
and find the people to come from with
the skills with the ones that you have
that's step number two number three I
start looking at talking to my customers
and see you know talk to the ones who
have bought from you in the past see why
they stopped buying from you or see why
they are buying from you talk about the
type of things that they want to see
improvements if it's in the service and
new product offerings you can come up
with and as soon as you have money
coming in from new customers it solves a
lot of problems with the business so get
them up or talk about the new vision
talk about the team you have in place
make them feel comfortable and confident
that you're going to be able to take the
business to the next step especially
they buck you in the past
they seem that the company has gone
under you might have some work to do to
rebuild that relationship with them but
if you can get that mob or you have
money coming in I can help get your
company on to that next step so I hope
that helps so get the vision in place
make sure you have the right team and
insert comments your customers enough to
get you on the right track to be
building this business I hope that
helped with your question if you guys
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up and leave a comment below I'd love to
hear what you have to say about it and
we'll see you for the next episode
you